hey cousin tonight we're making this
delicious so easy and creamy salmon
pasta for dinner I'm using Papa dele
pasta they're flat broad noodles I
picked up at Trader Joe's but use the
pasta you have on hand I boil on salted
water for eight minutes then I drain and
set aside I Pat my dry piece of salmon
on both sides I add salt to the skin
side then I flip I add a little oil a
little salt black pepper paprika and Pat
it in I add a little oil to My Pan on a
medium-high heat and I place my salmon
skin side down I let it cook for six
minutes then I flip and cook for another
four minutes I like my salmon medium
well in the same pan on a medium flame I
add some butter 4 grated garlic cloves a
cup of heavy cream I add some black
pepper salt paprika I grate about a cup
of gruyere cheese because I love this
cheese and then I add about half a cup
of Parmesan cheese I combine until it
melts and then I add in the pasta gently
combine the pasta into the sauce it's
really magic on its own I add the salmon
a little of the pan sauce over it some
extra cheese for Razzle Dazzle and enjoy
cousin